so I'm ready for drink we're in Vegas by
night
what's more fun than 50 bartenders in
Vegas you're able to perform in Las
Vegas you're top of the line
Vegas is a playground it is wild and out
of control we're gonna have as much fun
as we possibly can but I wanted to do
well in the competition welcome to Las
Vegas
I'm literally competing against the best
bartenders in this country this is
pretty epic though right yeah bartending
is probably the best thing that's ever
happened to me in my life you kind of
party for a living you're having fun
blending flavors together the skill and
practice of it this is an art and it's a
craft I am a chef I just do it with
liquids instead of with food I just
don't think it represents what this
competition was about nerves can get the
best you shake the nerves out of your
body cuz you're gonna see some people
nervous up there to your drink do it
right
adrenaline is kicking in and you do what
you do or you step off the preparation
it's not
it's unfortunate because as emoji people
kill to be in this position terribly god
this terrible
I'm freaking out I'm super nervous all
day it's like intimidating how much you
can do this one crowd kind of went live
and nuts and the judges went wide-eyed
another way you know one of us is gonna
go on to win the whole thing
please will you announce the 2013 most
imaginative bartender it will change my
life